all right joining me now Ned Ryan
founder and CEO of American majority Ned
um they are running out of ways to try
to stop Trump but his point all along
has been they're coming for me because
I'm standing for you and I he's just a
standin for what they want to do to the
American people is that an overstatement
on his part or do you think that pretty
much is the pitch down the
middle no I I I think it's exactly right
Laura when you think of the attacks that
are being made on freedom of speech
freedom of thought free flow of
information the whole goal being to get
to the truth it's clear that the other
side in this debate is terrified of the
truth uh only wants the official
narrative and their propaganda to get
through and anything that's not that
they're going to label as misinformation
for fear that the American people might
fully understand the truth of how DC
Works what's actually taking place and
once they're equipped with the truth
vote accordingly uh of course they're
going after Donald Trump because they
view as an existential threat to the
administrative State and and some people
have said if Donald Trump gets elected
he's going to go on a revenge tour no
he's going to go on a restoration tour
he's going to work to restore us back to
a constitutional republic instead of
this ruling class and administrative
state that quite frankly has nothing to
do with a constitutional republic that's
what they're afraid of Laura they're
afraid that if Donald Trump gets back to
Power the status quo that I think's been
in existence for well over call it 100
years uh will be upended and that will
actually get back to the path of
restoring the Republic that's what
they're terrified that's what they want
to prevent by taking out Donald Trump
yeah when you when you turn over the
Rocks then a lot of stuff crawls out
from under the rocks and we're going to
see just how bad Washington is another
thing that they do Ned though of course
is they throw around charges whether
you're a violent extremist domestic
terrorist you know a threat to democracy
or they hint or or site racism as the
heart of the problem this is what
Leticia James said today what they
were were comments that unfortunately
fed violence comments that I would
describe as race baiting the comments
unfortunately that appeals to the bottom
of our
Humanity this case was brought simply
because it was a case where individuals
have engaged in a patent and practice of
fraud Ned uh that's where it is and she
is insisting that she's just following
the law it's just because there's a
pattern of fraudulent uh disclosures
about the purported wealth of his
companies and his businesses that that's
the only reason she's doing it she
expects us to believe
that I I'm I'm beginning to think
Leticia James doesn't really understand
how real estate investment loans Etc
real estate valuation works I think part
of that is complete ignorance on her
part I I do I do realize that when
people lack Merit in their arguments and
their case and understand they are
moving forward on the thinnest of
pretenses they always go back to name
calling when you revert to name calling
you've already lost the argument so for
her to go and say it's racism race
baiting that is is taking place I I
think it it's really a signal to me that
she realizes she's losing this argument
uh in in this case but again they're not
going to stop Laura I mean I I tell you
I will tell the listeners from now until
the elections in the fall of 2024 the
left will continue to use lawfare the
the legal system as a political weapon
to try and throw sand into the gears of
the Donald Trump campaign and hopes that
somehow they will prevent him from
winning in November of 2024 well I want
to go back to this uh Newsweek piece
that broke late today uh it's explosive
about the FBI targeting Trump supporters
everything that we expected it seems
like it is happening a senior Intel
official said that we've crossed the
Rubicon Trump's Army constitutes the
greatest threat of violence domestically
politically that's the reality and the
problem set that if the half of the
country Ned approximately a voting the
voting public right is is basically
siding with domestic terrorism I mean
that seems like it's licensed for the
government to take lots of Extreme
Measures to deprive them of their
Liberty well it feels like the president
last week saying you know America First
they're they're an existential threat to
the very soul of this country
dehumanizing demonizing this week we
find out from Newsweek that FBI is
actually trying to Target America first
as domestic terrorists again following
their trend pro- lifers Conservative
Catholics concerned parents at
Schoolboard meetings I think the real
telling that that article to me Laura is
when an FBI officer said well this would
apply equally even to the Democratic
party but their supporters aren't given
to violence dude did you Rip Van Winkle
your way through the 2020 BLM and antifa
riots in which there were billions of
dollars destroyed dozens and dozens of
lives cost by those riots and and real
domestic terrorists and what they're
telling us is well actually the real
terrorists in this country are the
prayer prayerful pro-life grandma and
those BLM antifa folks they're mostly
peaceful I think the thing that is again
terrifying to me is when you don't have
equal application of the law and use it
as a weapon there is no rule of law and
it also should become apparent to people
if that's how it's approached you're not
a citizen you're a subject yeah well
you're subhuman and you you can't govern
a country that you hate you can only
rule over the country that you hate Ned
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else